scps will come and go we know that but
the most important thing in life will
always be the anomalies at this
containment site right here right now
that's family thank you Dr Toretto for
that inspiring speech family can mean
many things to many people and when it
comes to the bizarre world of scps
family can be found in some very
unexpected places take the two brothers
Cain and Abel
scp-073 and
scp-076-2 respectively as an example
their shared history goes back centuries
and from a little we've been able to
learn directly from the source the two
seem to have the mother of all sibling
rivalries Abel can become visibly
enraged at the very mention of Kane's
name whereas Kane has a more subdued
response calmly but firmly urging
inquisitive researchers not to discuss
the matter any further whatever bad
blood came between them is not fully
known but it likely has something to do
with the nature of their anomalous
abilities Kane has the power to drain
the lives of plant life with merely a
touch while Abel has the power of
Resurrection returning from the grave
every time he was dealt a lethal blow
the two were natural opposites and yet
they were also undeniably family and
their case is not wholly unique within
the SCP Foundation as there is also
another pair of completely antithetical
beings in containment who surprisingly
share a family tree and much like the
dynamic between scp-073 and
scp-076-2 there was one side of the pair
that could express nothing but distress
at the mere mention of the other and it
was by far not the one that most would
expect enter
scp-682 one of the most deadly ketter
class scps that the foundation had ever
known a reptilian monstrosity
responsible for multiple containment
breaches capable of withstanding the
total punishment of weapons both
conventional and anomalous and hell-bent
on following through on the personal
violent destruction of every living
being in existence it is an anomalous
creature so overwhelmingly powerful and
in instructable that one could easily
assume that it was incapable of fear and
in most cases that would be an astute
observation but not when it comes to the
matter of scp-999 the Tickle Monster in
stark contrast to scp-682's viciousness
scp-999 is a bundle of pure
unadulterated Bliss resembling a smiley
face glob of sunshine and honey
scp-9999's main anomalous property is
its ability to bring lasting joy to all
beings that interact with it for long
contact with the little guy has even
been proven to cure depression and ease
trauma what's more
scp-999 seems to actively seek out
others to share these benefits with and
often does so through play or other
forms of socialization
scp-999 is benevolent in just about
every way that a being could be and that
makes it very different from most of the
Sapient anomalies in containment it is
especially different from SCP 682 even
though they have a common origin while
the family resemblance is far from
striking these two scps are half
siblings not as closely related as Cain
and Abel but that is still a lot closer
than most researchers would expect both
of them were allegedly born from Human
mothers who had undergone a horrific
ritual at the hands of an obscure cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King as the ominous name of the cult
implies the members of the children of
the Scarlet King worshiped a nightmarish
deity known as The Scarlet King this
interdimensional super being has become
known to the SCP Foundation as one of
the most threatening anomalous forces in
existence and some have even suggested
that the Scarlet King is the ultimate
threat that the foundation must overcome
if they wish to achieve their goals to
put it a different way the Scarlet King
is like the last boss of a traditional
RPG video game a primal source of all
evil and suffering in the world which
must be defeated at any cost his powers
are so great that our world is merely
one of many that he aims to conquer and
reduce to rubble and ruin and all of us
mortals can take a bit of solace in the
fact that the Scarlet King split
interests mean that he is unlikely to
invade our world directly anytime soon
he is not without his schemes and
contingencies though of which the vile
machinations of the children of the
Scarlet King were surely one the two
ordinary human woman who would go on to
give birth to both scp-682 and scp-9999
were part of a group of seven
individuals total all of whom had been
imprisoned by the children of the
Scarlet King and were found in the late
stages of pregnancy at the Colts
compound upon being discovered by the
SCP Foundation these women were placed
in containment and designated
scp-231 over the duration of their
containment the instances of scp-231
have given birth to various anomalies
most of these anomalies have been
catastrophically dangerous ketterclass
anomalies and have each been the cause
of hundreds of casualties those which
could be destroyed through violence were
neutralized before ever receiving a
designation with the obvious exception
being
scp-682 despite the foundation's best
efforts even more exceptional is scp-999
which while just as anomalous and nigh
indestructible as the others did not
share its siblings capacity for cruelty
and Slaughter of all the humans that
were unlucky enough to become part of
scp-231 only the mother of scp-999 was
able to survive and make a full recovery
from the trauma that she suffered at the
hands of the cult this unexpectedly
happy outcome was apparently thanks to
scp-9999's ability to heal those around
it including its human mother
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile and
scp-999 the ticklemont monster are the
two most notable members of The scp-231
Brood and while the Scarlet King had
more than likely hoped that his actual
biological children would join forces to
drown our world in misery and pain this
will most likely never come to pass that
is because
scp-682 and scp-999 are like oil and
water and the one that has been
successful in Rising above the other has
unmistakably been as CP 999 this
surprising truth became known to the
foundation after a rather eventful
cross-test between the two most contrary
spawn of the Scarlet king and the
findings from that experiment Point
towards a possible long-term solution in
dealing with the interdimensional Elder
evil as well as his children adopted or
otherwise the cross test was the product
of resilient optimism from the research
team who Against All Odds were willing
to bet that scp-999 could survive an
encounter with one of the most infamous
Qatar class scps the foundation had on
record nobody could be 100 sure that 999
would come out of the test unscathed and
there was not an insubstantial amount of
fear as everyone's favorite glob of
goodness was wheeled into a shared
containment for the experiment to be
carried out however the mere presence of
scp-999 did Sue the great deal of the
worried Souls which only instilled more
confidence in the head researchers that
this would lead to a success once
scp-999 was alone in the cell with
scp-682 the main event could begin
scp-682 had been subjected to a wide
variety of cross-tests during its time
in containment and having never met or
been aware of scp-999 prior to the test
was cautiously staring the creature down
preparing for the absolute worst with a
beaming smile on its face
scp-999 slid forward towards the reptile
causing the ketterclass SCP to
instinctively step backward in response
there was something deeply unsettling
about out this gooey little glob to
scp-682 but it couldn't fathom what from
appearance the overseers of the Cross
test were stunned the site of 682
retreating from an entity was rare to
say the least and the adorable
unimposing shape of scp-999 made the
scene playing out inside the containment
area especially surreal but no matter
how unlikely it seemed scp-999 had begun
The Sibling play date with an
insurmountable psychological advantage
as the Tickle Monster move ever closer
scp-682 found itself packed into a
corner with no further options the
reptile brought one of its massive claws
down on top of the smiling blob the
entire mass of scp-999 was splattered
into jelly upon impact for a moment it
seemed as though that was it the
researchers held their breath in shock
hoping that scp-9999 would pull through
and then their wish came true the
amorphous form of scp-999 began to
reshape itself into the recognizable
form that we all know and love it
proceeded to crawl up scp-682's body
towards the nape of its snack once there
the Tickle Monster began doing what it
does best cuddles and lots of them 682
was certainly caught off guard by this
unusual occurrence and more than that it
was falling fast under scp-999 spell of
benevolence the lizard began to stomp
its claws overcome with sun bounce of
uproarious laughter it began to vocalize
in a way that seemed
uncharacteristically enthusiastic for
the ketterclass anomaly happy happy I
feel so happy repeated 682 as it rolled
around and thrashed in the cross-testing
containment chamber the merciless
tickling from scp-9999 looked like it
would be torturous for the big reptile
to endure if it wasn't so much fun on
the sidelines the foundation Personnel
cheered on their wonderful little friend
999 as it continued to tickle scp-682
without stopping some of the staff
present or even sporting custom t-shirts
that read
scp-999 literally cured my depression
the Tickle Monster did have a large fan
base within its containment facility
after all and returning some of the Good
Vibes that the anomaly had provided
seemed like the right thing to do at a
time like this
scp-682's fits of laughter continued for
a long while and the more it went on the
more it seemed that scp-682 was becoming
tired 999 seemed to sense its siblings
energy level decreasing ceased the
Relentless tickling and instead began to
nuzzle 682 and purr into the lizard's
ears slowly the quiet and pleasant
sounds of scp-999 lulled 682 into a
peaceful Slumber the hard to destroy
reptile curled up on the floor of the
containment cell almost like a sleeping
cat and began to gently snore away once
it's older and more cantankerous sibling
had fallen completely asleep
scp-999 slithered off
scp-682's back and settled down nearby
to rest its own eyes the research team
couldn't help but smile and observe for
several minutes before eventually
removing 999 from the cross-test
containment cell predictably this caused
scp-682 to revert back to its usual
violent behavior and a Containment
Breach ensued shortly after however the
casualties were kept to a minimum as
scp-999 bravely helped escort several
dozen Foundation Personnel to safety by
itself what would we do without you 999
we know what scp-682 would do without
scp-9999 of course the hard to destroy
reptile would be far less threatened
while scp-999 had expressed continued
interest in another play date with 682
the exact opposite sentiment has been
reported from its reptilian sibling and
it is simply not a lack of affection
there is an underlying fear that
motivates
scp-682's desire to never interact with
scp-999 again while some researchers
speculate did that scp-682 felt an
incredible sense of Shame when it was
observed being tickled this is more of
an armchair assumption that projects
typical human psychology onto an
anomalous being we cannot forget that
scp-682 was born of the Scarlet King and
while scp-999 possesses the inverse of
its father's traits
scp-682 might have directly inherited
the template for its emotional
intelligence from that very same being
While most well-adjusted humans try to
avoid supposedly negative stimuli such
as embarrassment anger sadness and fear
and seek out positive stimuli I.E
happiness pleasure security and Trust
alien beings with Twisted Minds like the
Scarlet King might have these priorities
reversed to scp-682 all other living
things are disgusting and it wishes to
destroy them but when this tendency is
examined within the context of both
scp-999 and what we know about the
Scarlet King it'd be becomes clear that
scp-682 isn't an excessively prideful
being moreover
scp-682 doesn't believe that it is doing
the world or itself a service by
eliminating the aforementioned
disgusting beings we have theorized that
scp-682 and scp-999 are equal and
opposite but if that proves to be true
on the level of internal psyche
scp-682 might compulsively attack other
beings for the same reason that scp-999
Comforts them it is a continuous
expression of empathy or more accurately
whatever one might call The Impossible
inverse of empathy
scp-682 and the Scarlet King are not
merely indifferent to the suffering of
others both of them need to be in the
presence of those suffering beings in
order to feel any sense of meaning in
their existence after all love is the
strongest emotion but hate is the second
strongest imagine now if you can why 682
fears 999 a being that represents every
unwanted sensation and emotion that it
lives its Immortal Life hoping to avoid
in the eyes of scp-682
scp-999 is precisely as horrifying as
the reptile is to ourselves want an
anomaly of your own check out
scpswag.com for high quality SCP merch
now go check out scp-001 no match for
the Tickle Monster and what does scp-999
do all day hour by hour for more
adventures with scp-999